[Music]
hello cole sprouse and cole sprouse's
butt yeah cole shared this pretty
surprising snapshot to instagram it's
not hard to figure out it's been
photoshopped call giving himself a
digital bbl yeah i mean i think you have
to poke fun it a little bit eagle-eyed
fans might notice what the image
actually looks like in the camera frame
the unaltered photo in the camera seems
to be just cole's face and the caption
for this pic good morning to my
publicity team yeah it doesn't take
jughead and betty's investigative skills
to figure out this might just be an
inside joke for cole's publicist i'm
weird
i'm a weirdo and speaking of the
residents of riverdale freddie andrews
opening his house to a bunch of snakes
here goes the rest of your north side
boat buddy we're all neighbors here all
right bacon cole's co-stars weighed in
on the funny shot skeet ulrich who plays
his dad fp jones on the hit cw drama
commented with a row of laughing emojis
vanessa morgan and mark consuelos also
chimed in in the comments
yeah as long as you can keep it fun and
light it's all good cole's kinda known
for his sense of humor and if you're
doubting us check out this moment from
his interview with et back in march
where he offered up his musical skills
for his moonshot co-star lana condor's
wedding you guys started wedding
planning yet that's also a very intense
period of life yeah we have actually
started wedding planning um cole is not
invited but um it's going to be great
it's true
oh you want invited yourself
well on paper i'm uninvited but
realistically i'm the guy way in the
back and like a wide-brimmed black cat
standing by the tree and everyone's
going like who's that mysterious
person
no but we have started wedding planning
it's uh it hasn't been stressful for me
i uh
then there's this moment from last
month's met gala cole opening up about
his playful side you were posing up a
storm down there
what kind of character are you
channeling tonight um
man
man covering for his awkwardness
probably is the character
you awkward never
humor's the greatest defense mechanism i
swear man works every time
[Music]
you